When you have some goal out here that
you're stretching for and reaching for,
that takes you out of your comfort zone,
you'll find out some talents and
abilities you have that you didn't know
you had.
When the messenger of misery visits you,
what are you going to do?
One,
we'll keep you in the gate.
There are things that you think you'll
never need to know
that you may only need to know one time
in your life,
but that could save your life because
you have that knowledge unless you
to do something beyond that which you've
already mastered,
you will never grow.
What is it that you looked at at some
point in time and you decided that you
couldn't do it,
that you talk yourself out of it.
You're waiting on your next door
neighbor to make it happen for you.
It may not happen if you're waiting on
your mother or your father.
They may be so ancient in their thinking
that they don't understand this
opportunity that you have and if you're
waiting on them and they never get done,
but don't beg average people to be
phenomenal.
You don't beg good people,
the people nominal.
You just are phenomenal and you want to
try phenomenal.
What reason can you remember that you
can call on the chicken restaurant that
can make you get back up?
Find that reason if you're not where you
are,
if you're not where you want to be,
if you don't have what you want to have,
if you're not where you think you should
be at this particular place,
it has nothing to do with the system,
but it has everything to do with the
fact that you're not making the
sacrifice.
I want you to make that dream become a
reality because if you don't,
you will be working for somebody else to
make their dreams become a reality.
Everybody is against you or don't
believe in your normal.
Let me tell you something that's a
lonely feeling.
It's a lonely feeling,
particularly people that you're doing it
for.
Most people take their greatness,
take their ideas to the graveyard with
them.
I said to me,
if it was easy,
everybody would do it.
There are people right now who are
working who don't want to work.
There are people who hate their jobs,
but they keep getting up to do it.
The wealthiest place on the planet is
the graveyard.
The graveyard,
we will find inventions that we never,
ever were exposed to.
Ideas,
dreams,
and never became reality.
Hopes and aspirations that were never
acted upon.
Question is,
what are you going to do with your time?
What drives you?
Greatness as a lot of small things done
well day after day after
day after day
when things don't work out for you.
When things happen that you could not
anticipate,
what are the reasons that you can think
of?
I'm only talking to the people that are
ready to get to the next level of they
life and they're going to boldly walk
into the next season of their life.
Unapologetically getting rid of all
things people in situations that no
longer belong in their life.
Most of you,
most of you,
you're so consumed
with everything that's going on in the
world.
This is the reason you haven't figured
out your own life yet.
Every blog,
every website,
every tweet,
every instagram post,
you are so consumed with everything
that's going on in the world.
You're ignoring your own world.
You can never shy and trying to sit on
someone else's son.
You can never figure out who you are,
if you're consumed and everything that
everybody else is and what they're doing
in the moves that they're making because
you're trying to chase someone else's
life.
You trying to chase someone else's
lifestyle and identity all while
ignoring your own life and your own
path.
What is the vision for your life?
What are the ideas and the dreams for
your life?
What are you supposed to be doing?
Who are you?
What are your gifts and talents?
What is your ultimate destiny and your
goals
and you should understand this,
that it was always going to be your
family and your friends.
That would be the first ones to try and
talk you out of your vision and your big
idea.
That's why you supposed to live your
life focused on your intentions and do
your thing.
It's you allow your self worth to be
based on what other people think of you
as the beginning of the end.
I believe in me.
If you stopped believing in me,
I'm not going to believe in myself any
less.
If you believe that I'm irrelevant,
that no one is checking for me and that
I don't mean anything to the world
because you think or believe that about
me,
it doesn't mean that I'm going to
believe it about myself.
See,
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion is
the beginning of the hand.
Most of you guys don't actually know
your self worth.
You don't know yourself.
Value,
believe in yourself.
Believe in yourself,
independent of the validation of the
world.
Have opinions and feelings about
yourself,
independent of the feedback.
I really think,
and if you get rid of the trash in your
life,
it can be people,
businesses and situations you couldn't
really like.
I really believe that you can reach your
full potential.
I want you
to fly.
I want you in your career and your
financial blessings to bypass me.
You know,
I never want to be that nine to five
person that just lives my entire life
working a nine to five and just be happy
with a modest lifestyle.
Um,
you know,
being secure.
A lot of people,
that's all they want.
They just want a secure lifestyle,
you know,
own a house,
and be able to retire and that makes
them happy,
you know,
and I just believe that we should always
be always be pushing,
you know,
to achieve more.
It's become more,
you know,
and sit at a job.
The same job for 30 years is not
something I would ever choose to do in
the society.
You know,
we,
we are tied to go to college and get a
job.
That's what we're taught.
If you become a doctor or a lawyer,
you're successful,
you know,
but
most of the time you still have a boss
still have someone you know Tony what to
do and you still have a schedule you
have to stick to,
you know.
So it's not much different than working
at Mcdonald's.
I mean,
it's just you're making more money,
but you're still
working at Mcdonald's or
money,
lifestyle freedom that you want when you
want to know is the most people don't
understand that you've got to work hard
at whatever you do,
whether you're working for someone else
or working for yourself.
If you want to put that in,
you know you're going to end up being
successful,
but that's what keeps us going.
You know,
when you become content over
the mentality is what's going to make
things happen.
You know,
is having that mentality and never give
up.
Keep pushing forward and trying to
accomplish your goals and hopefully you
have more goals constantly trying to
move on to bigger and better things and
find a,
improve ourselves in every area.
You really have to believe what you're
doing is working.
You know,
it's very important to believe you have
to believe to achieve.
If you're doing something you're not
hundred percent competent,
we're doing,
you're going to fail.
You know,
someone who is doing maybe not 100
percent correctly,
but they truly believe in their mind
that they're doing the best they could
possibly do.
And they believe what they're doing is
the best possible scenario.
I think they're going to have a lot more
success than someone that is doing it
100 percent right,
but aren't positive and what they're
doing,
you know,
the mind is the most powerful tool we
have.
And in order to be a winner,
you have to lose,
you know,
that's,
that's how you learn.
You know,
one day I made him tell him he better
get out there and start busting your
ass,
you know,
going forward and never stopped.
Don't miss a day,
you know,
one day Mrs can't
back.
Always.
Always look at the positive.
You know,
the glass is always half full.
If you think positive and you look at
the positive,
you know you're,
you're only going to continue to get
better.
And it's been positive in every area is
the secret.
It's the secret to life.
If you're negative about anything,
you're going to fail.
No matter what it is.
You're not happy.
Do you want to be better?
But you want in every aspect,
like if you want to better yourself in
every way.
A lot of people,
somebody else,
and it just what comes around goes
around.
The most important thing is to not give
a shit what other people think,
you know,
that's the most important thing to have.
That kind of an attitude and mentality
is rare.
You know,
people are always concerned about what
other people think,
no matter who they are,
it really doesn't matter what other
people think,
you know,
it really doesn't matter if you can have
that kind of mentality.
People don't like to think they like to
ask and they don't have enough
confidence in their decisions that they
make on their own.
When they get advice from someone else,
that gives them more competence to
believe that that's gonna work.
We should always be trying to be better
at every aspect in life.
I mean,
you know,
are you a good husband,
a good wife?
Are you a good son?
You know,
are you a good,
you know,
whatever it could be.
You know,
there's a million things in life that we
are,
we,
I think we should constantly be trying
to be better in every area.
I kinda liked to just,
you know,
relax,
enjoy life and that's Kinda what I do.
Um,
and being able to,
to not stress and do what I want to do
when I want to do it is just a great
feeling.
What changes our whole life is action.
Why don't we take action,
fear or are we going to do to get
ourselves to do it?
Well,
you got to make sure that we push
ourselves through.
If I'm making a decision,
the point in which change happens is a
decision.
Every change in your life that you want
will come from something simple.
A decision.
People,
what does making change decide
if I persist,
if I continue to try,
if I continue to charge forward,
I will succeed.
I will persist until I succeed.
I was not delivered unto this world in
defeat.
No,
just fair your course in my veins.
I am not a sheep waiting to be prodded
by my shepherd.
I am a lion and I refuse to talk,
to walk,
to sleep with the sheet.
Don't be a follower.
Be a student.
Take advice but not orders.
Take information,
but don't let somebody you know order
your life not to do what someone else
says.
Take what someone else says.
Processing.
Think about it.
Ponder.
It makes you wonder.
It makes you think,
then it's valuable.
Then when you go take action,
make sure that the actions,
not what somebody told you,
make sure the action is the product of
your own.
I'm exactly where I wanted to be because
I realized I've got to commit my very
being to this thing.
I got to read it.
I got it,
and until you get there,
once you get there,
I guarantee you the world is yours.
Stay out of the clutches of mediocrity.
Invent.
Reinvent yourself.
Change your toe shape so often that they
could never categorize you.
Reinvigorate yourself and accept what is
be self taught and reinvent your life
because you must live.
Your life
belongs to you.
Wait,
not
everybody
is putting in place.
Happy place this
pain.
You can only have two things in life
reasons or resolved.
Notice reasons don't count.
False will always point out reasons on
why they are not living their dream on
why they're not manifesting their
greatness.
They will always be able to point those
things out,
but none of those things count.
The only thing that counts the results
and results don't lie.
Ladies and gentlemen,
they tell it all judge a tree by the
fruit that it bears,
not the ones that it might talk about,
not the ones that it might wish for,
but the fruit that it actually bears,
the people that are committed are busy
doing it,
but I think that some of us are
producing results in our lives that that
level of commitment brings that we
particularly don't like or find
distasteful.
You want to take care of yourself.
I don't think that as a participant in
life,
you cannot be committed.
You either committed to mediocrity or
you're committed to greatness.
You're either committed to being
productive or your committed to me,
nonproductive.
You committed to being happy or you're
committed to being unhappy.
Once I look at how you commit your time
one time,
do an evaluation on how you spend your
time.
I can tell you exactly what you're
committed to.
People that say they have dreams of one,
open a business or wanting to do
something differently than what they're
now doing.
They don't like.
Their jobs are unhappy,
they're unfulfilled.
People said they want to improve their
income level.
Look at how they spend their time.
Commitment shows up in your life,
in what you do.
You can make the commitment to your
life,
but you know black,
the results that you have and that
you're going to do something about it.
See that power is available to all of
us.
People who look at life,
I want something different for myself,
so most people like to use that
language.
They don't want to commit themselves
because commitment means among many
things.
No,
it's feels is acceptable.
If you decided that you want to joe
this,
if it becomes it difficult,
if it's inconvenient,
so what would your life be like if you
decided to keep your commitments?
One will be like if we decided to keep
our commitments,
but we decided to do the things and we
said that we were going to do,
but we wouldn't even speak it unless we
were going to do it.
Say,
I will do anything.
I'm going to do it.
Seven days,
you'll feel strong and powerful.
There's nothing as powerful as the human
spirit.
You can't destroy
when you walked the minute you're
dancing to the beat of a different
drummer.
Don't expect people to understand.
Don't expect it to make sense to
anybody.
Why you got to do this?
This is a good job.
I'm
going,
I don't understand.
You don't have to
look to this day for his life,
the very life of light in its brief
course lie all the realities and
verities of existence,
the bliss of growth,
the splendor of action,
the glory of power for yesterday is but
a dream and tomorrow is only a vision,
but today,
the day well lived makes every yesterday
a dream of happiness and every tomorrow
a vision of hope look well.
Therefore,
to this day,
a journey of a thousand miles begins
with a single step from an old Chinese
proverb.
Most people have heard it or have come
across it at some point in the meetings.
Pretty straightforward,
right?
Advocates having the courage to take
that step towards the goal and let's
keep making that decision to move
forward towards something you want,
but it's what happens immediately
following that first step that I'm
interested in.
What happens when the journey's begun
and it's you and your goal in all of a
sudden you realized how long that road
ahead.
Really,
this is a turning point for a lot of
people and those who can succeed or able
to take their daunting,
intimidating goal or journey and see it
for what it really is.
Just a bunch of small manageable tasks
strung together.
You know when you look at why people
quit,
a lot of the time it's because they were
overwhelmed by their goals and
ambitions.
Let's say you have this wonderful plan
in your head to climb a mountain.
You're thinking about that feeling of
being on top,
looking down with pride.
Every time you think about it,
your heart starts racing,
so you pack your stuff,
you make your way down on the base of
the mountain,
and then you look up
different ballgame right now,
the entire mountains in front of you and
you realized that that's no small feat.
That is when people walk away,
when they aren't able to see a
challenge,
is the sum of tiny steps.
They see it as a crazy,
impossible task.
It's like saying you want to be the next
Tom Brady or coby Bryan to tall mountain
to climb,
like trying to hit a target from a mile
away,
but if you can identify and map out what
you need to conquer in order to become a
better basketball player,
football player,
and begin taking those small steps,
improving everyday,
that makes real.
That's what gives schools like
the ability to see your objective not as
a marathon,
but as a series of little 400 meters
stretches,
stepping stones.
You know what your objective is today,
tomorrow,
the end of the week and the end of the
year,
and then completing them day by day.
These little victories.
That's what gives you a dream life.
It's what gives you momentum.
You feel good about the process,
and by the way,
when things blow up in your face,
which happens every so often on this
little place,
we call them
birth,
you'll have that foundation and that
sense of accomplishment to stay focused
because you're approaches tangible and
it's realistic.
This applies with everything.
Losing a job,
a breakup,
failing a test.
These things are monumental.
If you allow them to know,
they can turn into that unclimbed bubble
mountain
or they can roadmap a new path for you,
and if you define what you want,
you define success and begin stepping
towards it one hour,
one day at a time,
you'll get where you want to be quicker
than you thought.
How you can live an easy life,
you know,
accomplishing goals and be successful in
going out in the world and as tough.
The only way to live an easy life is to
basically give up on all your dreams and
aspirations and just sit around doing
nothing.
Shit.
The disease is not worth accomplishing.
Therefore,
a life that is easy.
It's not even worth living.
Nothing in this world,
it's worth having or doing,
unless it means effort,
pain,
and difficulty.
What you listening to me,
you listen to be good.
You are going to die.
All of you,
you or your friends,
your family,
everyone you know,
everyone you care about.
It's gonna be if you love life,
not waste time because time is what life
is made of,
so if you respect and appreciate the
time that you've been given,
why you out there doing what you want to
do,
where you need to be,
telling yourself is an acceptable to be
sitting around procrastinating and I no
longer wants to be a loser.
I no longer wanted to be offered.
I know what it is that at one and I'm
going to work hard and I'm going to get
it.
When you want to succeed,
as bad as you want to breathe,
then you'll be successful.
Suddenly you lost sleep.
More success,
and I'm here to tell you today,
if you're going to be successful,
you've got to be willing to give up
sleep.
You got to be willing to work for three
hours of sleep,
two hours.
If you really want to be successful,
some days you will have to stay up three
days in a row,
but you don't need to
if you don't really want it.
How badly are you wanting success rather
than actually working towards your
dreams?
A lot of you are just thinking about it.
I have high hopes for everybody watching
this.
I want you to remember your name.
It is not the things we do in life that
we regret on our deathbed.
It is the things we do not because I
assure you I've done a lot of really
stupid things.
None of them bother me.
All the mistakes and all the dopey
things and all the times I was
embarrassed.
They don't matter.
Find your passion and in my experience,
no matter what you do at work,
what you do in official settings,
that passion will be grounded in people
grounded in the relationships you have
with people and what they think of you
when you were talking
in the teeth of these stupefying odds,
which is you and I,
you know,
ordinarily are here,
but one thing I can tell you ever single
day of my life trying to find somebody
else change their life.
I waited till 39 to get married because
I had to wait that long to find someone.
Her happiness was more important
and if nothing else,
I hope that all of you can find that
kind of passion and that kind of love in
your life.
Thank you.
Most people don't even make a resolution
anymore.
Why?
Because they made him from years and
years and years and they know they're
not going to follow through.
So after a while,
who wants to disappoint yourself?
Who wants to be upset with yourself?
Why even bother to set a new standard
for this year?
You know it's going to be the same as
last year.
Many of us don't act because we want
other people's approval.
We want everybody to like us and to
accept us,
and that's not possible.
Many of us don't do the things that we
want to do and don't act because of lack
of self confidence.
We don't believe enough in ourselves.
There's no denying that inside of you.
They only thing that's gonna make you
happy and but you're adding the decades
ahead.
It's going to be having you have an
experience where on a regular basis you
feel like your life is making progress,
so it's got to be a vision that's
compelling,
something that you know it's going to be
a gift to make sure that it happens.
If you want to do anything worthwhile in
life,
you've got to be hungry.
Josh Todd and working to develop myself.
He said,
I want you to practice everyday being a
disc jockey.
I said,
but I don't have any job now.
He said,
it doesn't matter.
He said that it's better to be prepared
for an opportunity and not have one than
to have an opportunity and not be
prepared.
No excuse that.
If you decided that you want to do this,
if it becomes hot and do it hot,
if it's difficult,
so yes,
beginning of the year we have this
tradition,
but it goes beyond tradition.
It's something inside of us that makes
us want to make things better and I
think part of it is the calendar gives
us this idea that we could have a fresh
start,
that we can start from fresh and have
this great victory and it's really.
The calendar itself is quite arbitrary.
It's wonderful to use it,
but if you didn't use it effectively,
let's use the Kennel under served you
today.
Let's just see what does it really take
to make this thing happen?
Because there's no denying that inside
of you.
The only thing that's gonna make you
happy and but you're adding the decades
ahead.
It's going to be having you up an
experience where on a regular basis you
feel like your life is making progress.
Just think,
what would your life
be like if you decided to keep your
commitments?
It is important and the area of
motivating yourself.
It's important to know why you're doing
it because that mind will say,
why bother?
Why go through all this?
This is too hard.
No,
throw in the towel.
It's not worth it.
If you make the change in yourself,
you're going to be proud this year and
no amount of money or accolades from
other people can mirror the feeling of
being proud of knowing you've taken back
control of your life or you've taken a
great life to another level because once
you do that,
you have something you can give other
people.
Would it be your kids or your friends
and your family and ultimately that's
why it's about.